[Applause]
yes we made it to August what I call
hump month now I took it we were off
last month in July I took some time off
to come back strong I feel it's fresh
and invigorated as robert muller at a
hearing it's terrible but good news
Trump left Washington DC for the weekend
today see he can reduce crime in a black
city
I noticed you groaned a little first get
hurt black and crime before hearing what
the meaning was don't [ __ ] do that
but even for him he had a racist fee
month get up July today he told Dora the
Explorer to go back to the City of Gold
and of course he told for Congress women
to go back to the country who came from
and Melania said how come I never get
that option him the least racist person
in the world in the whole way you don't
even at least racist person at the
Cracker Barrel well today his ass
kissing Lackey that he had appointed for
a Director of National Intelligence kind
of an important job he withdrew even
Republicans were like this guy's to
school it found out he was an idiot a
partisan hack and a compulsive liar so
he's staying in Congress where he
belongs
ok
but it's amazing Trump doesn't vet
anyone
it's the bureaucratic version of not
wearing a condom why bother when you can
just pull out
you keep thinking but hey good news we
got a budget deal not really good news
it raises the deficit hundreds of
billions of dollars on top of the
trillions we've already run up on the
card but don't worry it's okay when
Republicans do it it's like eating when
the refrigerator door is open those
calories don't count if the but you're
probably still excited about the debates
this week you watch the debates I'm sure
that the Democratic candidates
Democratic candidates when after the
president heart unfortunately the
president was Obama did you watch the
debates cuz that happened yeah the guy
with the 97 percent approval rating
among the Democrats his [ __ ] is not woke
enough now
yeah Trump saw that he called Putin he
said I got this one
those debates were lively it was a
chance for viewers of course to hear 20
different versions of America that was
just from Kamala Harris and of course
Biden being the front-runner he got lit
up by everybody Harrison Tinsley and
Booker and Castro and Gillibrand they
all hit him and you know is this helpful
I mean Americans don't follow politics
that closely I mean half the country
Tunes in and goes why is everybody
yelling at Bob Barker
and it you know at the end I mean Joe is
getting on in years a little at the end
when the candidates all try to you know
get people to contribute to their
campaign Joe invited people to visit his
phone number I don't have a joke for
that and I don't need one
just getting on in years come on when he
has weird sex his safe word is speak up
what the zinger of the night was a Cory
Booker did you see that when he said to
Joe he said you're dipping into the
kool-aid and you don't even know what
flavor it is I don't know what that
means but today Kamala Harris just made
it her health care plan
you